the good news i do have some good news
here even as the left has totally
rejected redemption
i do have some good news people are
beginning to turn
on the left minnesota right now there
was a poll
the mpr news star tribune k-a-r-e-l
minnesota poll was just released on
saturday about views on black lives
matter and a validly marxist
organization
that exacerbates this very issue we've
just been talking about
people were asked do you have a
favorable or unfavorable opinion of the
black lives matter movement
46 of poll respondents said
they have an unfavorable view compared
to 42 percent who say favorable
more people dislike the blm movement now
then like it i wonder why it turns out
when you burn down people's cities
they they don't like you very much they
don't think that's
particularly productive doesn't help
anybody obviously
blm says we need to defund the police
four out of five black voters say we
should not defund the police there's a
chasm opening up here
between what the ideologues think people
should want and what people
actually want one number one
statistic has me a little worried though
i like those statistics i like
that the hispanic vote uh viewers of
telemundo thought trump won the debate
i like that more people in many
minneapolis and minnesota are turning
against blm
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
you